WHEN THEY ARE IN TROUBLE,
LIBERALS BLAME THE GIRL.
THAT’S WHO THEY ARE.
AND I WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU TO
THE WOMAN NANCY PELOSI IS
BLAMING.
ERICA JOINS THE NOW FAMOUS LINE
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND SHE JOINS
US TO AN IPO THINK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
>> THINK IS A MUCH FOR HAVING
ME.
>> Tucker: NANCY PELOSI CLAIMS
ON KARMA THAT YOU ORCHESTRATED A
"SET UP" TO ENTRAP HER TO
GETTING HER HAIR BLOWN OUT
WITHOUT A MASK.
DID YOU?
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Tucker: HOW WOULD YOU HAVE
DONE THAT?
CAN YOU PROVE THIS WASN’T A
DIABOLICAL SET UP DESIGNED TO
BRING DOWN THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE BY BLOW DRYING HER HAIR?
>> SHE HAD CALLED A STYLIST IN,
OR HER ASSISTANT DID COME AND
MADE THE APPOINTMENT, SO THE
APPOINTMENT WAS ALREADY BOOKED,
SO THERE WAS NO WAY I COULD’VE
SET THAT UP.
AND I’VE HAD A CAMERA SYSTEM IN
THERE FOR FIVE YEARS.
I MEAN, I DIDN’T GO IN THERE AND
DRINK AMAZON AS SOON AS SHE
WALKED IN AND SET HER UP.
SO THAT IS ABSOLUTELY FALSE.
>> Tucker: PELOSI SAYS SALONS
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
OF COURSE, SHE LIVES THERE AND
SHE’S THE MOST POWERFUL
DEMOCRATIC LEGISLATOR IN THE
WORLD, BUT SHE SAID SHE
UNDERSTOOD THE RESTRICTIONS
ALLOWED A ONE-ON-ONE APPOINTMENT
IN SALONS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE ON THAT?
>> I HEARD THAT, AND I THOUGHT
TO MYSELF, WELCOME AS A
HAIRSTYLIST, I SEE CLIENTS
ONE-ON-ONE.
SO, THAT WOULD MEAN THAT I WOULD
BE OPEN, RIGHT?
>> Tucker: YES.
[LAUGHS]
SORRY I’M STARTING TO LEFT, IT
WOULD MEAN THAT.
ARE YOU OPEN?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS THAT DOING
TO YOU AND YOUR BUSINESS?
>> FOR THE PAST SIX MONTHS, I
MEAN, WE ARE PRETTY MUCH DONE.
I MEAN, WE’VE LOST AT LEAST 60%
OF OUR CLIENTS.
I’VE LOST THE MAJORITY OF MY
STAFF, SO, SIX MONTHS IS A LONG
TIME TO BE CLOSED DOWN.
>> Tucker: YEAH, NO, IT’S TOO
LONG.
SO YOUR BUSINESS HAS BEEN
DESTROYED BY THIS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT SEEING THE
MOST POWERFUL WOMAN IN AMERICA
COME INTO YOUR SALON IN
VIOLATION OF THE RULES SHE
SUPPORTS, GET CAUGHT AND THEN
BLAME YOU FOR IT?
>> TO BE HONEST, IT WAS MORE
HURTFUL.
SHE’S BEEN COMING IN FOR QUITE A
WHILE, AND JUST TO SEE HER
COMING AND NOT WEARING A MASK
REALLY GOT TO ME BUT THIS ISN’T
EVEN POLITICAL.
SHE’S BEEN COMING IN THERE.
IT’S THE FACT THAT SHE ACTUALLY
CAME IN DIDN’T HAVE A MASK ON,
AND I JUST THOUGHT ABOUT MY
STAFF AND PEOPLE NOT BEING ABLE
TO WORK AND MAKE MONEY AND
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES, AND
IF SHE IS IN THERE COMFORTABLY
WITHOUT A MASK AND FEELING SAFE,
THEN WHY ARE WE SHUT DOWN?
WHY AM I NOT ABLE TO HAVE
CLIENTS COME IN?
SO, IT’S BEEN HARD.
>> Tucker: IT YOU YOU’RE NOT
MAKING A POLITICAL POINT, YOU’RE
MAKING A HUMAN POINT ROOTED IN
COMMON SENSE AND I DON’T KNOW
WHAT THE ANSWER IS, WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE IS?
IF NANCY PELOSI FEELS
COMFORTABLE USING YOUR SALON,
WHY CAN’T CIVILIANS USE IT?
>> I WILL BE HONEST, IN OUR AREA
IN SAN FRANCISCO, WE ARE
OBVIOUSLY THE LAST CITY OR
COUNTY DID NOT OPEN.
WE’VE BEEN TRYING TO FIGURE THAT
OUT.
WE’VE BEEN ASKING OURSELVES
THESE QUESTIONS FOR SIX MONTHS.
FOR THE PAST ACTUALLY FOUR
MONTHS.
OF WHY WE ARE NOT REOPENED, AND
IT’S KIND OF A GOOD QUESTION.
AGAIN, WE DON’T KNOW.
>> Tucker: WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO COME ARE YOU GOING TO STAY
IN THE CITY, DO YOU THINK?
IN SAN FRANCISCO?
>> I DON’T THINK SO.
THE HARD PART OF ALL THIS IS
THAT I’VE BEEN IN THAT COMMUNITY
FOR 12 YEARS.
SINCE THIS HAS HAPPENED, I
RECEIVED NOTHING BUT HATE TEXT
MESSAGES, DEATH THREATS, THEY’RE
GOING TO BURN MY HAIR SALON
DOWN.
UNBELIEVABLE.
WITH BAD REVIEWS.
IT’S JUST SAD THAT MY COMMUNITY
IS PULLING THIS, WHEN THEY ARE
SAYING THAT I THREW HER UNDER
THE BUS WHEN I DIDN’T.
SO THAT’S HURTFUL, BUT YEAH, I
THINK I’M PRETTY MUCH DONE NOW.
SO, YEAH.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT IS ONE
OF THE MOST HEARTBREAKING
STORIES I’VE HEARD IN A LONG
TIME.
A LONG TIME.
I JUST WANT TO STATE FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HATING YOU FOR
TELLING THE TRUTH, I DON’T
CONSIDER THIS POLITICAL, YOU
DON’T SEEM LIKE A POLITICAL